ciao anche chi chiede ospiti wetter un
sogno che mi ha traumatizzato e che vi
ricordo che io e tutti in vendita mia
famiglia tavole garage e misuravano
quante dita della mano non riusciva
momento
perché vuol dire che vuol dire oh
ragazzi mi vengono da me ragazzi sono
dieci ciao ragazzi bentornati a una
nuova puntata di vita buttata buon 2019
il tema della puntata di oggi è sogni
assurdi
si sa che l'inizio di ogni anno è pieno
di buoni propositi e pieno di sogni
meravigliosi ma la vera domanda che mi
sono posto e che ho anche letto 3 vari
commenti tra vari suggerimenti essi ok
tutto molto bello ma quando poi si
spengono le luci e uno va a dormire
quali sono i sogni più strani che
abbiamo fatto
così ho deciso di chiamare cui un ospite
particolare un ospite che se ne intende
assolutamente di sogni un visionario
ecco del nostro secolo che ad essere
l'attimo impegnato con il quale
commentare e analizzare soprattutto
alcuni dei sogni che abbiamo ricevuto
ospite degli studios di casa mia è
niente poco di meno che mio fratello
gian luigi
ieri tra le gt che che competenze ai a
livello di psicologia 09 perfetto siete
in buone mani cominciavo assegnato che
miss contavano le ali che mi crescevano
le ali l'italiano super contenta ma per
per realizzare che per usarle uomo
prevenire trasformate non ha fatto
chistina gallina e quindi manco la
riservi una gallina dalle inutili non lo
ha detto il fatto di non poter volare
celio anche io preferirei fare le uova e
però saper volare
cioè no adesso quanti di voi qui un uovo
1 al giorno però tu puoi volare ma lo
vuoi mangiare quindi è pure la colazione
saltare anche alta altra cosa e come ti
riproduci l'uomo è un nuovo non
necessariamente tu fai un nuovo da loro
vedi con una volta o signore di doveva
trasportare di pinguini ten l'iceberg
all'altro ma sarò fargli il solletico
sulla pancia tiravano insieme diventano
piccoli piccoli piccoli a quel punto
basta non mettersi in tasca viaggiare
verso l'altro iceberg problema io ho
dimenticato di bwin
che brutta persona che sa come fatto a
dimenticare un pinguino immaginati lì da
solo sarah rimasto lì potrebbe voler
dire che lei stava riuscendo a gestire
facilmente alcuni problemi della sua
vita o comunque alcune cose dovrà fare
la sua vita e poi ha avuto una svista
questo con la paura di che tutto vada
troppo bene che quindi ti sei vergando
questo perché si carica troppo sulle
spalle i problemi di tutti sono convinto
di questo si è poi soprattutto si sa che
nei sogni e proprio a livello
psicologico che i pinguini rappresentano
i problemi della finanza si si si
anche i grattini io sogno e i piedi di
mio nonno nel letto e la stessa notte
energia sogno il busto di mio nome non
cresce mai a letto ma ti capiti abbiamo
fatto affrontare perché sono al busto
con la teca di piedi non sono esaminate
non lo sto capendo il quale la struttura
il suo nome
io quello che ho capito questo è un
gusto ma sportivo come nonostante questo
e questo sono da giovane sono la ragione
era così sono allora giovane lui cioè
per forza altrimenti io capisco ho
sognato di svegliarmi perché qualcuno
stava bussando violentemente alla porta
di casa mia e quindi nel sogno sono
andato appunto a vedere chi fosse alla
porta una volta aperta in casa mia è
entrato un essere deforme grigio con una
pancia con fissi ma e delle canne
sottilissime nudo tra l'altro che ha
iniziato a saltellare ridendo verso la
camera di mio padre che mi sono
svegliata di soprassalto ma la cosa
inquietante è che mio padre
la mattina dopo mi ha raccontato che
verso ignoto di aver percepito qualcosa
che correva nel corridoio e che si
avvicinava alla camera sua e che poi si
è svegliato di soprassalto quando ha
sentito che si infilava velocemente
sotto le sue scoperte
tutto comunque è quell'uomo ragazze odio
o l'appetito comunque cielo sulle gambe
terrificanti vi sta andando ovunque
questo è il sogno più terrificante più
terrificante di tutti ecco diamo un
significato a questo sogno abbiamo un
premio a questo sogno se il più
terrificante quindi è come se milioni ed
è cominciata
è come se la figlia effettivamente fosse
andata ad aprire la porta
non aver capito no sono stupido non ho
capito no volevo descrivere bene quel
conto mamma rialzo per una grande
lavoratrice la propria rapina grande
narratrice sì c'è ha detto quelle due
cose che bomber aver smantellato
sì sì sì ridendo e saltando così a sera
allora ti prego io di sinistra né ne
faccia quantità industriale sono più
brutto è stato quando ho segnato il gesù
che mi imponeva di guardare i dio mentre
apriva un vangelo e del solo io
soffocavo perché si era una luce
tremenda che li accettava poi gesù come
se nulla fosse richiude il vangelo non
riapre e l'inizio punto è datato io che
soffro e questa luce abbagliante che tu
non hai sugli strani praticamente sogno
di riuscire ad avanzare cioè mentre
cammino a un certo punto c'è qualcosa
che mi tiene una forza che cercano forse
ti sta facendo andare perché spiegando
che dicevi praticamente non riesco ad
andare avanti quindi comincia ad
arrancare ad arrancare in altro che
mettermi a quattro zampe terra è
terrificante e terrificante mai capitato
di uscire a muovermi tipo molti mi
dicono molti mi è capitato di essere
troppo leggero e più spingo era ho
sognato che esorcizzano enrico e non è
riuscito mi sono svegliato detto gatti
non ci sono grossi
ciao ciao allo speed volevo raccontare a
giocare a nascondino col gioco ma
leggete dove sarebbe più fortunata io mi
nascondevo per loro urlavo dicendomi è
inutile che ti nascondi tanto sentirò in
quinto superiore ricordo d'aver sognato
sei i personaggi sempre diceva di essere
citava l'opportunità di vivere in una
struttura nazista per un giorno così
potevamo raccontare l'esame di stato
un'esperienza che ho vissuto sulla
nostra pelle sfide piscità psi
analizzarmi ne sarei tanto cinese beh di
sicuro non le piace per niente tra
l'altro però questo sì credo che ti
faccio schifo dragon ball e credo che
questa sia una grande analisi e ti
possiamo regalare mi dispiace
si muove lo scarico in due con di
ragazzi ma basta no non fa ridere dai
cioè ogni volta che apriamo bocca
giacolone rispettare non è il rispetto
ok natale che le vacanze ma no tutte
quante qua ve prego uno studio che
arriva majin bu fattura di una volta ho
sognato che cristiano ronaldo veniva a
casa mia a giocare a scala quaranta mia
madre mio fratello a mangiare una torta
che hanno cucinato mia madre e poi
decideva di andare a farsi una doccia
nel bagno di casa mia e io stavo seduta
sul divano e pensavo a cristiano ronaldo
si fa la doccia da ma è un'altra volta
invece ho sognato che katzav oh the rock
perche non aveva rifornito le caramelle
nel negozio in cui lavoravamo capisci
invece di bonn barberia sangue prepara
doccia io so seduta è l'altro lo script
ma quel sogno resta comunque non penso
sia l'unica assegnarsi cristiano ronaldo
è però no tu ma che tu pagarmi nevole
cristiano ronaldo che poi secondo me c'è
anche la leggenda che lui capito no ci
siamo capiti ci volevano sentire non
dobbiamo analizzare la sessualità dava
infatti da questo sogno e ma comunque va
beh non penso tu sia l'unica dai hanno
manco il sogno
[Musica]
la commissione o dice non praticare un
secondari mentale aiuto sia vasto
ragazzi ma sembrano che stava un buco
entrasse andavamo giusta se comunque
mentre lo stavo di farmi non ha per
niente di esplicito perché è una bella
come quello conosciuto ai ricordi alle
di navigazione volta sognato di fermi a
mare di doccia e rassegnato difendere il
numero di enrico r3
infatti dice e dopo aver sognato di
farmi aricolo riuscivo più a guardare le
tue stories se c'era lui vediamo se si
può creare un match in diretta ma
attenzione noi khrin non vendiamo sogni
ma solide realtà ragazzi sia ragazza
mazza dio e contro l'altra foto vieni
qui davanti ma non è non sia una posta
del cuore
un giorno con tardi ma ho visto solo ora
il posto in cui lancia dei sogni allora
ricerca molto spesso di fare sono
estranei che diciamo che il sogno audio
strada e un narratore che più recente
diciamo pure suoi sardone nucleo ma io
ti racconto solo una fase san paolo è
stato quello in cui io lui se l'è
trovato è seguita da altre peripezie
sotto un porticato con questo porticato
incontro alberto angela che se ti at 16
ferme prima del diluvio il bari sai
quando un genio ha modo di vivere 95
anni e esprimere tutto il suo genio
viene appunto definito genio cosa
succede se un genio a modo solo di
vivere per tu 95 giorni e di non
esprimere il proprio genio bene questo
viene definito aurico ecco il card
ero commosso di questa cosa ringraziamo
perché continuava a dirmi altre cose
positive su di me non aveva senso tutto
questo
e posso dire che a volte faccio questi
ragionamenti di alberto angela che penso
sempre
perché quello che stiamo realizzando un
sogno analizzando un dilemma
esatto penso sempre che il motivo per
cui per i numeri nella vita devi cercare
di viverla al massimo perché domani non
è mai una risposta ed è per questo che
questa vita buttata su quel sito c'è una
voce troppo tv cioè magistrato ha meno
mezzi infatti nella sezione a me la
sentivo ma poteva anche dirmi bubo bubo
avrei detto sì è vero
ciao a proposito di sogni strani ti
volevo raccontare quella volta in cui ho
sognato di riuscire a vedere la donato
vitale delle persone è stampata sulla
loro testa da ogni riferimento death
note puramente casuale stavo camminando
e ho visto nei sogni o una signora mano
nella mano presso bambino che stavano
salendo solo appartamento bene la cosa
brutta è che sulla testa della persona
vedevo scritto tipo un timer 10 9 8 7
una volta che arrivato ovvero la porta
si è chiuso il todi loro perché è
rallentata in casa ecco la cosa bella è
chi non ha fatto assolutamente nulla ma
ne sono altamente sbattuta nel mio
inconscio vuol dire che sono una persona
lì a roma il 10 0 di rifarmi a
soccorrere quel povero bambino che
avrebbe avuto una madre che gli umori
vado avanti chiamare un'ambulanza
ad esempio il telefono o soccorrere quel
povero bambino il momento in cui sarebbe
rimasto da solo visto che era
piccolissimo con una donna che dico
morta mentre in casa e allora si
ponevano al freddo e aveva il freddo
cioè magari non ha visto cosa diceva
allo scadere del timer quindi ma moriamo
noel ha detto che vedeva la vita della
persone questo lo dice lei ma non c'è
nulla di concreto la casa è vero il
bambino quindi che un tema diverso l'ha
lasciato fuori come lei l'avresti
abbandonato il problema sono le cento di
chi però è la prima volta che faccio in
tempo a darti un messaggio vocale per
raccontarci qualcosa non glielo diro
uguale vostro amato una reggi cante ma
enorme page una cosa che mi spaventa c'e
ancora tanta dal pensiero infatti sotto
e realizzata dalle api la mattina dopo
che mi sono svegliata raccontando a
mamma il sogno e hanno detto vorrei che
stanotte incominciato a corre per tutta
casa come una bambola come la
psicopatica eletto ha tranquillizzato e
abbiamo pure parlato chiesta cosa che
non mi ricorda ogni altro corso per caso
spaventano la famiglia era svegliata
parlando di hostare c'è una matta è un
episodio sul bullismo credo che la linea
mia cugina che una volta dormiamo
insieme o 13 anni le si sveglia le
macchie sono sporche di sangue
con questo accordo
e poi si era addormentata e forse la
minaccia dei problemi una volta si è
alzata ciao ciao ospite queste la voce
ma sto facendo questo locale con un
piede nella fossa fa la notte sognai che
chiedere mimì vogliamo dire tutti quanti
che gianluigi qui dopo aver vomitato il
suo peso corporeo per tutta la notte
grazie all'editore un professionista un
applauso niente scriviamo sotto hashtag
professionismo alzare professionismo che
partecipando ad una sorta di canada
parlo per organizzare il party più bello
che si parti erano a tema e noi non
sapevamo quale fosse il nostro entriamo
in questa sala buia accendiamo le luci e
scopriamo che c'erano un milione di
finiti letteralmente di qualsiasi tipo
forma e dimensione e il nostro compito
era organizzare appunto una festa a tema
quindi organizzando varie attrazioni
quelli che per i folli e ad esempio il
tocco di classe alla fa la creiamo un
piccolo angolo di natura nel quale
riproduciamo questo prato fiorito con
questi tutti colorati che disponiamo un
po di fiore quelli più duri
il metallo li appende al muro per creare
gli appendiabiti creiamo anche una sorta
di percorso ad ostacoli
ovviamente tu dove c'è una certa
andrebbe percorso che si faceva con le
liane dove appunto dove prendere un
mondo passare l'altro per i cocktail
inutile dire che quelli fluorescenti
erano dati ai partecipanti come l'hai
stick per la vista
insomma fu una festa divertente molto
strana con tanto di amazzoni che
ballavano la pole dance ed ovviamente
vincendo il contest un bacio e le è un
film
praticamente un sogno che facevo spesso
da bambina e non nel garage di casa
entravo una macchina dei miei genitori
accede una macchina e mi schianta voto è
praticamente da denti gara si accendeva
0 100 subito ma dentro il garage
secondo te quindi sistemi chi ha subito
accettato se viene mischia stavo ragazzi
siamo arrivati alla fine di questo
silvio sì che dire io ringrazio tutte le
persone che hanno mandato dei messaggi e
soprattutto ringrazio le vostre menti
malate perché alcuni di questi audio mi
hanno terrorizzato si erano molto amici
nel senso cioè retroporti caldi strong
vabbè ringrazio gian luigi il premio
ringrazio perché sei stato molto 8 per
questa mutata e soprattutto volevo dirvi
che quest'anno vogliamo fare le cose in
grande e quindi vogliamo migliorare vita
buttata se qui sotto potete mandarmi
oltre che delle idee di temi che più
potrebbero interessare allo stesso tempo
volevo chiedervi se avete magari dei
consigli per rendere ancora più
interessante o per arricchire in qualche
modo questo format quindi per farlo
evolvere costantemente che dire io a
questo punto ti ringrazio giallo
ringrazio voi vi ricordo di iscrivervi a
questo canali attivati campanelli di
fare quello che vi pare qualora vogliate
rimanere aggiornati su quello che
facciamo e niente li mando un bacio e ci
vediamo al prossimo video ciao ciao